in the very beginning just started
because my family loved to spend time
together by watching movies so I always
grew up movies in the house that the
first time I remember seeing a film on
the big screen was the 1993 release of
the old Star Wars films and I remember
watching a new hope and there's ever any
chance we could do anything else I
always knew it was interesting and
fascinating and I was always playing the
characters whether they were on the
telly at the same time or not and then
when I was nine I cast androids came to
my school in North London and said is
there anyone who likes acting you know
we're casting a film and the teachers
put me in touch with the casting
director and and I auditioned for this
film and I didn't have any idea about
the process really but there I was on a
set and there were all these interesting
people and I got to stay up late and it
was really exciting and I got to do the
thing I loved most in the world which
was play pretend and then I got a
hundred pounds at the end of it which
was a huge amount of money to
nine-year-old me that's a lot of comic
books I asked my mum what the money was
for she said that's what he got paid for
doing the film and I never really
realized before that moment that people
actually got paid to act I thought it
was something that people just did for
fun so I always knew I wanted to be an
actor but my parents said stay in school
you know when you're 18 if you want to
go to drama school then absolutely and
the dream never died so I went to drama
school and came out four years ago now
getting the role of Sega in Krypton is I
mean a literal dream come true in the
sense that it was only that this wasn't
only really occurred to me in dreams
because it was so far away at the point
in my career where it happened I was
still very very new I was I was in
theater and doing sort of costume dramas
and that sort of stuff and I was still
very much learning and still AM and then
my agent sent me the email to do a self
tape for this thing called Krypton now
singing this is a massive American thing
they're not gonna they're not gonna pay
attention to me why would I be any use
for it and I taped for it and I meant I
went in to meet the amazing Priscilla
John who's the UK casting director and
Collin McCarthy who directed the pilot
and I had a lovely audition but I didn't
think I was going to get it so I was
very relaxed and I just had a good time
with it and sure enough two weeks later
my agent said you didn't get it when I
was like well surprise
but it never went away because usually
with the job that's the last you hear of
it
but every few weeks or so you know they
cast him cooler in my agency what was
camping up to and so we sort of knew
there was something going on and
eventually it led to a screen test in
Los Angeles which was a bizarre
experience but but really really
wonderful and again it was the sort of
thing that I thought you know you have
nothing to lose so this character in the
scene can be played in a very sort of
stoic way in a very sort of grounded
kind of way but I thought you know
there's a lot of comedy in these lines
so as long as you're here you might as
well have a bit of fun with it so I
think I went in and I think I was
probably the first person to make them
laugh and the material sort of came
naturally after that and the first thing
that David Goyer said he was here of
mine legend in comic books and in film
and the first thing he said after seeing
me on camera was that was awesome so I
was like all right okay I'm in with it
I'm in with a shout here I think you
absolutely feel the sense of
responsibility because it's Superman
it's something that means so much to
millions and millions of people and I
get that because he's important to me
too I am a fan and I actually think that
helps sort of allay any fears because I
understood that all of that passion and
all of that desire to get it right comes
from love and the fans love this and
that's a good thing that's a useful
thing to have as an artist and that is
something that grounds you and just
makes you all the more determined to do
a good job with it it really grounds you
I found it very useful I didn't let
myself believe it was happening and I
think that's very sort of natural
response for a lot of actors you don't
really believe it until you're there
doing it and even then you don't believe
in it till is off the cutting room floor
you know the the first feature I did was
a film called Florence Foster Jenkins
and I had a small role but I had a scene
with Hugh Grant and and it was amazing
it's been great to work with him and I
liked the scene I liked the lines and if
you watch that film you can actually see
me go and say my line and I do this and
then it cuts away to the next shot so
that entire scene ended up on the
cutting room floor so that happens
that's a reality of it but hey I still
got to work on a Stephen Frears film
with
all Street which is amazing what's the
key to chemistry with other actors it
it's a very sort of ethereal thing
chemistry you never really know what's
gonna happen in terms of how you work
together I feel very lucky to be working
with George because her work speaks for
itself she's she's a master hero she'd
never say that and George don't watch
this I'm sorry for saying that but she
is so brilliant to work with an obvious
is great to watch her on screen but when
you're there and you're working with it
you get front-row see so I was learning
all the time from her and I was always
sort of open to everything she had to
offer to a scene and it was really great
for me to work with her and it's funny
cuz we have this story which you know we
sat down the first day in Serbia filming
the pilot she literally just got off the
plane we sat down next to each other for
a table read and Collin McCarthy
director the pilot looked at both of me
I said bond
we're like okay this is scary but George
is wonderful and she's really generous
and night and I think if there's
anything that's the key to chemistry is
just generosity it's been you know good
to each other and and feeling safe with
each other that's the main thing
auditioning is it's never an exact
science and it's really really tricky
and you can go to as many workshops as
you want but it's really hard to
simulate that feeling in the room of you
know being under pressure it took me a
year to get you know good but
auditioning because I used to freeze up
and I think that was the problem was I
was so obsessed with being good I was
like I have to I have to nail this part
and this I really want this and I've got
to go for this and and absolutely work
hard and no you lion's backwards and be
prepared and definitely have a take on
the character and have something to say
about it but I think that's the key go
in like your workshop in the role this
is your role and they want you to be
great so if you're going in there it's
just for the casting director or you
know the director producers no matter
what you're going in there and your
workshop in your version of this
character that version the character
will always be yours whether you get the
job or not have a bit of fun with it and
remember that whether you get the job or
not you're still an actor that's that's
sort of the main things go in there and
have a bit of fun with it how much
information you get beforehand for an
audition
again it's not an exact science you know
you might get quite a lot which is great
and generally the the further you get
along in the process you'll get a little
bit more information you'll be able to
make me read a script or even maybe talk
to a director or a producer or something
like that about the character but very
often you're not given a lot of
information at all you've sort of given
a very short brief like a few sentences
on who the character is and in that
first round that's kind of okay because
I think one of the things that let me
make peace with the audition process was
the idea that they're looking for you or
they're not you know you're you're right
or you're not and I remember one of the
main pieces of feedback I used to get
was you know he's just not the guy and
which is a really frustrating bit of
feedback to get because you don't really
know what that means but it absolutely
makes sense and having friends who are
on the other side of the camera you know
that they tell me a lot of the time the
best actor doesn't get the job it's just
someone who is right for the part
and very often in that first round of
self-types whatever it is when they've
cast a wide net they're just looking for
people who fit the archetype or whatever
it is they're looking for the character
I know nothing about the casting process
that's how I've justified it in my mind
but don't worry too much about that you
know whatever it is you're working with
whether it's just the scene or a few
sentences of a character by ogle
whatever it might be just do your best
with what you've got and you'll have
your take on end they'll like it what
they want you'll be fine either way
I've been we've all been there you know
it's really really hard when the phone
isn't ringing and you you feel like you
have nothing to do because you stop
feeling like an actor you feel like
someone who's just you know on the couch
or you're doing your whatever the other
job is you're I was folding clothes you
know at a store and that sucks it's
really horrible because you sort of lose
touch with that person who was excited
and passionate about it and I think
that's the main thing is I got to a
point where I was really upset going to
the movies which is my favorite thing to
do in the whole world because I used to
think I'll just never get there I'll
never be there and that was wrong of me
because don't ever forget why
love this don't ever forget that dream
like as cliche as it is to say you're
always an actor regardless of whether
you're working or not you can pick up
Hamlet and say you know what no one's
paying me to do it but I can play this
character you can pull through it you
can get your friends together into a
reading you can go to a play you can do
a workshop they always stay engaged as
much as he possibly can stay engaged
even if it's painful there are
challenges at every stage you know that
there's there's when the phone isn't
ringing she talked about a bit but once
I got the role of say girl I was really
scared
you know because I I had this moment the
first week of filming where I was just
like I I don't know what I'm doing they
got the wrong guy why am i I'm gonna
ruin Superman for everyone this is gonna
be a disaster and I was talking on the
phone with my girlfriend and I was
saying all these things being like I
suppose I feel so stupid I'm letting
everyone down I'm horrible I'm a rubbish
actor and she's like but you love this
no it's like oh yeah I do love this I'd
I'd do this for no other reason than I
love it and I think it's fun and I think
it's really really important for me
because I worry about that kind of stuff
I worry about getting it right which can
be a sort of poisonous thing in the
process for an actor and I always just
sort of think you know have fun if
you're having fun you can't worry about
being good and that's something I always
come back to
[Music]
[Music]